yesterday the Dow Jones Industrial
Average had once again a disastrous
disastrous day falling twelve point nine
three percent in a single trading day
that is just under 3,000 points
in one day if we look at the worst
declines in history by points yesterday
was the worst day ever now I know I said
this two weeks ago and I said it twice
last week it keeps happening and in fact
if you look at this biggest single-day
point declines in history nine of the
largest 15 point declines in history
have come in the last few weeks now
if we look at declines by percentage
which may be more valuable in some sense
yesterday was the second worst stock
market declined by percentage ever at
twelve point 93 percent the only time
that the stock market had a worse day
than yesterday
on a percentage basis was the day known
as Black Monday October 19 1987 a
historically bad day that's the only day
that was the worst day than yesterday by
percentage and otherwise you're looking
at worse than the 1920s Great Depression
numbers okay not the 2008 Great
Recession yesterday stocks were down
more by percentage than during any day
of the Great Depression of the 1920s
think about that and this has now wiped
out all of the gains of the Trump stock
market of the last 38 months when Donald
Trump took office the Dow was just a few
points under 20100 that's where we ended
yesterday 20,000 188 we're back to where
we were all of the gains of the Trump
administration are gone and
unfortunately this level of erratic
stock market performance and the
declines are likely not over we could
have a long way to go entire industries
are unfortunately going to be decimated
so the question is what can we do the
Fed printing money is having minimal
impact the usual suspects are going to
get bailed out the airlines the
cruise ship companies and many more but
what about individuals what about small
businesses there's going to be some
capital injections money made available
through small business association loans
there will be some other stimulus but
there will be businesses destroyed by
this I don't know how the countless
restaurants that are currently relegated
to takeout and delivery only survive
this their landlords are going to want
rent unless rent is suspended or
forgiven or made up by the government
many restaurant owners are gonna say I
just have to walk away I have to walk
away from the restaurant even with rent
support given by state or federal
government states or state or federal
governments many restaurants are not
going to survive because they're just
not going to make enough money and of
money so right away we probably need a
combination of some kind of universal
basic income for people making under X
amount or businesses whose gross
revenues are under Y amount I don't know
what those those numbers are but we
probably need something like that Mitt
Romney has suggested a thousand a month
ROH Khanna has a proposal that's a six
thousand dollar one-time payment for
people making under 65 K we need
something like that number two we are
going to need the government to step in
and say we will make or guarantee
mortgage payments rent payments I mean
I'm thinking out loud here all
non-essential travel is going to have to
be stopped what counts as essential
travel I don't know but you've got to
define it somehow people need to stop
moving around red states are filled with
people just partying at beaches in close
proximity these are idiots these are bad
people some of them may be Donald Trump
yesterday finally saying this is not
under control
will make a difference and it's tragic
in many ways this is why it's crucial
that we grin and bear it
now we stay home we try to turn the
corner on new infections but it is not
looking good the latest numbers as of an
hour ago were a hundred and eighty eight
thousand official cases worldwide I mean
the number is probably millions
worldwide at this point there are
estimates that Ohio has a hundred
thousand actual infections there are
estimates that the country the US has
five hundred thousand or seven hundred
and fifty thousand in we just don't know
we know the death toll
currently has past 7,500 and we must get
it under control the economy will suffer
for a while it's this is going to be
ugly but if we don't work together it's
only going to be worse let me know what
you're doing
what are you able to do on Twitter I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman follow me let me
know what you've got going on check this
out the first 500 people who see this
video and go to david pakman.com slash
skill will get a premium membership to
Skillshare for two months completely
free skill shares the online learning
community with thousands of classes on
almost anything you can imagine always
taught by experts they have classes on
drawing painting photography video
editing web design running a small
business and much more I recently took a
very interesting class called simple
productivity how to accomplish more with
less and got a bunch of great personal
productivity tips out of it we should
allow ourselves a little time every week
to either get creative keep your brain
sharp learn something new it's great for
mental health and almost all the classes
are under an hour so it's very easy for
someone who's busy to take advantage of
it with skill share you can discover a
new passion explore something you didn't
know you would enjoy but there's also
plenty of classes for people with
experience so you can just get better at
something you're already good at and
again the first 500 people who see this
video and go to david pakman.com slash
skill will get a completely free premium
membership for two whole months giving
you access to every class Skillshare
offers check it out I put the link right
underneath this video